with love and joe settling down in the
quiet suburbs with baby this has to be
the slowest season yet right
don't get hysterical i took a seminar
hey
i'm gonna need more tarps you season
three is back with all the panty
stealing and awkward mom dialogue you've
grown to love no i should have known the
marriage was over two years and when
your father stopped wanting to do anal
in this video we'll be going over the
ending of season three some of its
biggest unanswered questions and what we
can expect for season 4. and trust me
there are quite a bit of clues peppered
throughout the season as to why joe ends
up in paris i put a time stamp below if
you just want to skip to that but before
we get into it make sure to like and
subscribe seriously only eight percent
of you are subscribed because you know i
wolf you so hard okay that sounds a bit
weird the last episode is called what is
love what is love
[Music]
nope not that it's a double entendre
what is love refers to joe's wife as
well as the question itself particularly
for joe or should i call him will
bettelheim or maybe it's nick like what
he's called at the end of the season
when he's in paris i wonder if he calls
himself nick since it's the main
character from f scott fitzgerald's the
great gatsby a book he mentions
frequently at the beginning of the
season as being an inspiration to him
fitzgerald also wrote tender is the
knight the book naughty neighbor natalie
engler gave to him in episode 1. when
joe falls in love he obsesses we've seen
this throughout season 1 with guinevere
back season 2 and 3 with love quinn and
most recently marion bellamy in fact
much of the journey of season 3 is joe
and love falling into and out of love
with joe saying in episode 10 that his
marriage to love is like a prison i'm
not free
unless we both are maria and joe is
willing to do anything for those he
loves including murder joe is fresh off
the heels of murdering marion's
ex-husband ryan goodwin a drug-addicted
news reporter who abused the system to
gain custody of their child juliet joe's
impulse to protect those he loves
through subterfuge and even murder stems
from his childhood told in flashbacks we
see how young joe shot and killed his
abusive father in an effort to protect
his mother this pardon the pun backfired
as his mom would turn him over to social
services saying that it was in his best
interest to be put into a home so we can
see at a young age how trauma
specifically abuse and abandonment
shapes joe's outlook on life in season
three we're introduced to nurse fiona a
woman who like his mother was being
abused but this time joe does nothing
there's even a brief moment where he
could have pushed the abuser down the
stairwell but chooses not to later
telling his friend could have stopped
him
the last time i ruined my entire life it
made her hate me so much she put me here
so i thought with fiona i didn't want
her to hate me too it's later implied
that fiona was killed by this abuser and
if joe had just stepped in he might have
saved her life this is what's at the
core of joe's ultra protective
personality and he keeps this dark side
of himself secret because of his fear of
abandonment if someone sees the real me
it'll go away
for good it's abandonment that also
connects him with marianne she like him
grew up abandoned by her parents living
in several foster homes she knows what
it's like to grow up with no one they
both also have children children they
want to raise right in a proper home so
they don't turn out like they did marion
was a former addict and has since turned
herself around joe ends up hiding the
bloody shirt he got from killing ryan in
the diaper trash can when love arrives
home unexpectedly love has had quite the
night having to kill her young lover
theo after he found out she and joe were
keeping famous mom fluencer sherry
conrad and husband carrie in their cage
underneath the bakery in episode 8
cherie and carrie overheard love talking
about how she murdered natalie so of
course our murderous couple has to lock
them up until they can figure out what
to do with them i love the cage it's a
joe staple appearing in both the first
and second season and i'm glad as hell
it's back couples who cage together stay
together joe says he'll take care of
theo's body and of course this is the
perfect moment for love to bring up that
she wants another baby to which joe
replies i want nothing more in the world
so that was a [ __ ] lie the only thing
joe wants is to take his son and run
away with marianne but first he's got to
take care of theo's dead body
come
on okay maybe not fully dead and you'd
think joe would finish the kid off here
after all theo did sleep with his wife
but joe doesn't this has to do with a
few factors one joe doesn't love love
anymore two he sees that he's just a kid
and this wasn't his fault and three joe
already has a plan to get out of this
situation which doesn't require further
killing unlike love joe seems to have
some semblance of a moral code when it
comes to killing whereas love's attacks
are more emotional and spur of the
moment see gill and theo joes are
calculated and he attacks overwhelmingly
bad people see ryan this difference is
best articulated in episode two you
murdered our neighbor in a fit of rage
no regard for the consequences this you
act oh pure and noble like like you have
reasons for what you do what you do but
when i do it i'm crazy right so joe
knocks theo out with a concoction from
carrie's quote-unquote potion box
allowing joe enough time to orchestrate
his master plan while also getting theo
to the hospital this is part of what
makes joe an excellent anti-hero he's a
dude who does truly evil things but most
of the time these are for noble reasons
like to protect those he loves if joe
was downright evil the show just
wouldn't work love uncovers joe's bloody
shirt that when he hid in the trash and
suddenly she realizes it was joe who
killed marion's ex-husband she saw how
the two interacted at the library
fundraiser a few nights earlier and she
also knows how obsessive joe can get joe
is in love with marion and she can't
have that the climax of the season leads
us to a dinner of deceit where
everything is put on the table yeah
that's a bad pun joe and miss his love
for marion and we learn love
accidentally killed her first husband
james by overdosing him with a paralytic
called aconite and even though joe gives
love the opportunity for the two of them
to part ways amicably and co-parent
henry together love just won't have it
while love tends to the baby joe
sneakily grabs the cutting knife but
love expected this she laced the knife
with aconite which can be absorbed
through the skin it's the same paralytic
used to kill our ex and this is done in
an attempt to save their marriage so
that joe will be hers forever none of
this would be happening if you hadn't
grabbed a weapon
no one
will ever love you like i do joe this
descent into full-blown crazy was
foreshadowed all throughout the season
check out this line from love in episode
1. there's nothing authentic or
intimidating about me i'm just a
stay-at-home mom slowly going insane
love uses joe's phone to lure marion
over with the intention of killing her
but that plan goes by the wayside when
love realizes marianne was the victim
here joe lied to her convinced her he
was into her and went so far as to kill
her ex when marion realizes this saying
that she knew joe was too good to be
true she no longer wants anything to do
with him this combined with the sudden
appearance of miriam's daughter changes
love's mind she tells marian to run
which is exactly what marian does marion
talks of this quote tiny voice in her
head she calls this her real true love
that voice that tells you the truth even
if it hurts for marion this voice told
her joe was bad news but she suppressed
that voice and look where it got her
this conversation with marion makes love
realize she's been doing the same thing
but that
that little voice in the back of my head
that i've been suppressing this whole
[ __ ] time it was right it's not her
that's the problem it's joe i'm not the
problem
my husband is the problem so love
decides to do the unthinkable and kill
joe who is still paralyzed on the floor
or so we think as love readies herself
to slit joe's throat joe stabs her with
a syringe filled with aconite this was
all part of his plan he knew for weeks
that love was growing it in the backyard
and sensing love would use it at dinner
joe preemptively took its counter
adrenaline if you notice on the pill
bottle which he obtained from carrie's
potion box it says 45 minutes to take
effect so he legitimately was paralyzed
for a while until the adrenaline could
kick in and it kicks in right in the
nick of time his liquid form of aconite
is fast acting and is enough to kill
love we get this sad flashback of joe
tracking down his mother who abandoned
him she's with his half-brother jakey
just adding salt to the wound that joe
was abandoned but not his half-brother
his mother says sometimes
we need to start over
joey completely and that's exactly what
joe is doing with his life starting over
but how can he do that when there are
still two people in the cage a dead body
in his house and theo in hospital who
can identify him as the man behind many
of these murders simple joe does what he
does best and orchestrates an elaborate
framing job he's done this throughout
the past three seasons but most recently
with gil the anti-vaxxer who he framed
for the murder of natalie but this job
is going to take a lot more work first
he composes an email to the modrolinda
homeowners association by the way madra
linda roughly translates to beautiful
mother which is a perfect name for this
fictitious town considering one of the
main themes of season 3 is love's
transition to motherhood this email acts
as a fake confession outlining all of
love's motivation for murder it also
depicts joe as the innocent husband
caught up in this brutal murder-suicide
to make it more believable joe cuts off
two of his toes baking one into a pie
remember love was a baker and putting
the other in a small box of trinkets
alongside artifacts that link love to
the other murders here we can see
natalie's teeth which joe had previously
removed so that the body couldn't be
identified and here's gill's driver's
license joe sets his house on fire
ironically using his wedding album as
kindling he takes his son henry and
leaves him on the doorstep of dante and
lansing it was already set up earlier in
the season that dante and lansing were
having trouble adopting but as we hear
in voiceover joe says this is only
temporary he'll be coming back for henry
this master plan seems to work for joe
the investigation into the fire reveals
traces of his dna from those toes even
though no other body parts of his were
found with joe being dead this allows
him to start a new life free from
survivors like theo sherry and carrie
coming after him theo seems to have
mended his tenuous relationship with his
father while sherry and carrie
capitalized on their captivity by
writing a best-selling book caged a
radical couple's therapy technique by
the way they escaped by finding love's
hidden key that she kept in there even
our tertiary characters get a little
send off jackson and andrew take over
love's bakery while kiki and brandon
developed an at-home poison test
prompting them to name their new
daughter toxie now here is where we get
into the fun stuff speculation into
season 4. on october 13th 2021 netflix
released a season 4 teaser but before
you go off searching for it it doesn't
contain any new footage it's just a
confirmation that it's happening but
there are a few clues that hint at what
direction this series is headed first we
see that some time has passed when joe
dropped off henry at dante's he was just
a tiny baby but now he's a toddler
carrie and sherry have had time to write
a book and go on tour and joe has made
it to a cafe in paris france he says
that he looked for marion but she had
vanished changed phone numbers and
there's no forwarding address at her
home he says the end of their story
remains unwritten fitting that they both
share a love for books so it looks like
next season will indeed focus on marion
but i have to believe our paths are
destined to cross again there's a fun
fake out with a woman he believes for a
second could be marion and we also see a
chime of the cafe door almost identical
to that of the bookstore in new york
where we first saw gwynevere back the
barista calls out the name niche which
if you read the subtitles translates as
nick this is joe's new identity as he
exits the cafe we see the name of it le
chaser solitaire which means the lone
hunter if this is my pack i think i'm
meant to be a lone wolf the hunter and
prey symbolism has been set up
throughout all three seasons in episode
five we see marion's drawing of lupita a
famous french novella who kinda also
looks like her next to a fox you might
also be asking herself why paris why did
joe travel halfway around the world to
search for marianne there well marianne
is french
my first language i was born in paris
paris is also a mecca for art and marion
is an artist as we see in the final shot
there are shops lined with paintings she
also told joe that's where she'd
traveled to if she ever had to run away
with her daughter from her ex i was sure
ryan could never find us i would
grab julia and run to paris paris was
also the location joe suggested to love
they run off to in season two
what if we uh
what if we leave together you could
finish cooking school in paris there's
also the question of how joe got to
paris he'd need a passport well remember
that he's still friends with will
bettelheim a guy he originally met in
season 2 to talk about making him a fake
identity the two are still friends as we
see in episode 9 of season 2 so it isn't
too far-fetched to believe that will may
have helped him out here there are also
wild cards like joe's half-brother jakey
it'll be interesting to see if he ever
comes into the picture and finally mary
and herself what is she gonna think when
joe shows up a man who is supposedly
dead and whom love said killed her ex if
there's anything we know about joe is
that he can gaslight and manipulate a
woman to no end and i'm sure he'll have
some great excuse to win her back for
better or for worse but what do you
think's in store for you season 4 and
what are your thoughts on this season i
want to hear them in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe and for more bad
takes be sure to follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much
you